[Music]
my
name I'm uh coach Hao I win all majors
and uh now I reach uh 20 times we win
major major
Marathon I see everything in TV like uh
bing Olympic like champ I
see yeah that's good moral for
[Music]
[Applause]
me
gatum is honestly it's complete athlete
full package a great talent a great
person uh hard worker and always
disciplined she has it all and uh her uh
result showing it she is uh one of the
woman confidence for herself she's
confident with everything what she did I
describe her as a Silent Assassin you
can tell that she's very determined
she's very focused on what she does I
don't I think she's a very loud person I
don't think she goes out there and
really specifies her goals like publicly
to everyone I don't think she proclaims
them as such but you can tell from the
way that she talks and from the way that
she carries herself that she's very
determined um and she knows exactly what
she wants to do and I think her record
in major championships kind of speaks
for that itself as
[Music]
well
and Berlin has a Gabi winning yet again
it's not highly remember the name it's
got it
[Music]
Tom Ethiopia is world Champion here
in just I don't believe it just um when
two of them live together G and the
Kenyan ladies I I don't know that moment
it's very very tough moment until she
break from the Kenan
ladies my friend just were we don't know
what can you do and look at the time
2811 it is indeed a championship
record
[Music]
fore
speech
foreign
speech foreign
speeech
for speech
foreign
spee
for when she's go to hugene the
situation is not easy it's very very
tough situation I don't want to remember
that moment uh because as you know
it'san is a very very big
war all the family she don't have
information about family she don't have
anything about so she's here scared
she carry all this in her mind and uh
she become world
champion that is shown us how she's
strong foreign
[Music]
spee
speech
fore
foree
speech
[Music]
for
speech
speeech
fore
[Music]
speeech
and the government in war at that time
it's even if she's scared to come out
from the home I'm the one it's went to
home it's take to training and return
back maybe I call uh 10 times in a day
more nobody knows what's happened you
know every day I want to her home I take
to training I return back and to make
her comfortable you know otherwise she
don't come to come to out from home for
[Music]
training
fore
she's the one of the uh select athlet
still today but she have next race she
run in One race in Japan if she's uh uh
finish uh top
three uh for sure she's selected because
she's um back to back middle in world
champion nobody do that you
[Music]
knowe
spee morally you're capable of going
faster in the real world on the roads um
and that's what we'll be working towards
in the coming
months